[Music]  it's not about anything else except for  winning and we're gonna bring winning to  Miami  rankles Lester  [Music]  this be a third freak  [Music]  [Applause]  I've been dreaming about it the time is  now  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  are going to be judged about champions  [Music]  there'll be another hooray  share this moment with the crowd it's  pretty awesome  good I think we did real good  everybody's so warm and everybody just  greeted us with open arms yeah we've  made this a home the community is great  the nation is great everything's great  you have a great home great friends  anytime you really put it all out there  on the line I think that's something to  be proud of  [Music]  [Applause]